good evening i'm kerry grant
every year
our profession
loses some
irreplaceable talent
and this year last was no exception
gloria swanson
norma shearer
pat o'brien
raymond massey
johnny weissmuller
sam jaffe
sir ralph richardson
william powell
jackie cougar
but we can be consoled
because their talents will be seen again
and again
in the films they did so much to
illuminate
one such person was often the happy
center of these academy awards
as a presenter
as a master of ceremonies and once
for his performance in separate tables
a friend of mine
and a friend of so many of us
david niven
david was a gentle man a gentleman of
wits
and he'll be missed by all of us who
value style and taste
in the lives of those we love
ten years ago
david shared the master ceremony duties
at these academy awards
and it was at the event in 1974
that perhaps his finest
and certainly his funniest moment came
quite unexpectedly
and unrehearsed
just as he was about to introduce liz
taylor
there's a clip coming on
the award
for the best picture
is never likely given and now to divulge
the contents of this year's most
important envelope
is a very important contributor to world
entertainment
and someone
quite likely
uh
well ladies and gentlemen that um
that was almost bound to happen
but isn't it fascinating that
fascinating to think that
the probably the only love that man will
ever get in his life is by stripping off
and showing his shortcomings
uh
david living
a dear unforgettable man
we were all lucky to know him
i think it's most unfair of cary grant
to come out here looking like he does at
his age and making the rest of us feel
like we should be in a home for the
agent
the longest film nominated this year
runs three hours and 13 minutes the
shortest film runs only four minutes
tonight the importance of short films to
our profession is reflected in the
stature of the talents presenting these
awards he just received multiple
nominations in the past and tonight they
are contenders once again ladies and
gentlemen michael kane and jane
alexander
the field of short film is full of
courageous little cinematic equivalents
of the short story the comic strip the
abstract painting the small poem for a
limited audience and a dozen other
metaphors
some of the people who began long
careers with short films include frank
capra stephen spielberg fred zinnemann
william wyler george stevens walt disney
and george lucas
and this year's nominees may someday be
just as well known
for the best achievement in an animated
short film the nominees are
mickey's christmas carol bernie madison
producer sound of sunshine sound of rain
gida godel calaman producer
sunday in new york jimmy picker producer
and the winner is
sunday in new york jimmy picker producer
thank you very much members of the
academy first i have to thank my father
who always had confidence in me and knew
that i can do it and figured i was
playing around with clayton would keep
me off the streets and my mother of
course was always holding my hand
and sunday in new york could not have
been as good as it what is
without the great talents of scott
record andy stein and charlie coover and
i'd also like to thank steven starr and
fred milstein of the william morris
agency and i'd like to thank mitch block
of direct cinema and myrna post of myrna
post and associates hi amarna and hi mom
for best achievement in live-action
short films the nominees are boys and
girls janice l platt producer goody
two-shoes ian eames producer overnight
sensation john n bloom producer and the
winner is
the winner is boys and girls janice l
platt producer
along with my um partners in atlantis
films michael macmillan and seton mclean
we'd like to thank the academy this
means a lot to us
boys and girls was
a labor of love and we'd like to thank
the director don mcbrady for putting
that love on the screen
also to alice monroe writer of the
original short story
joe wiesenfeld for the script
alar kivelos
louis natalie
composer of the music a fantastic
cast led by megan follows and ian heath
for their continuing support and
participation the canadian broadcasting
corporation and in particular
roman malnook and nato harcourt
to telefilm canada
thank you
to magic lantern
to
this is for rose and cindy
and for our family and friends who are
watching across canada thank you very
much thank you
you